latest reports are in looks like they
came back with some new footage let's
take a look
[Music]
now it starts to come together that's it
huh well it's enough round up the troops
we've got a lot to discuss things just
went from bad to worse
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that wants to no clip into your
subscription feed today i once again
find myself trapped in the endlessly
soggy hallways of the back rooms the
analog horror series produced by kane
pixels and available right here on
youtube.com for the low low price of
free the last time we enrobed ourselves
in its putrid yellow wallpaper we
concluded that the world of the back
room seems to function a lot like a
level map in a video game you know how
in a video game there's a set map that
you're able to explore and that there
are walls or invisible boundaries that
make sure that you stay within the
acceptable area of play well the way i
see it that's the real world here in
kane series the bounded area that humans
are allowed to play in however video
games also have tons of things that are
hidden in spaces outside the boundaries
of those levels unused ideas spare
assets cut content you want to know why
fnaf security breach's file size was so
huge when the thing first came out
something like 80 gigs of content well
it was just piles and piles of cut stuff
full floors of geometry that weren't
accessible in the course of normal
gameplay but hadn't been removed from
the game's files and that my theorists
are what i expect the backrooms are the
content the spare assets the ai
generated worlds that didn't quite make
the cut for reality last time we
proposed that somehow the company async
was able to use electromagnetism to tap
into those parts of the map the ones
that exist outside the boundaries of
reality beyond the parts of the world
that we're meant to see given us the
various repetitive corridors of the back
rooms as we know them now since the
release of that last theory kane has
come out with three new videos the first
is pitfalls where one of async's
researchers descends deeper than ever
before in the back rooms only to
discover an entire underground city the
next was reports where we see the
immediate aftermath of that incident and
async sealing the entrances to the back
rooms and finally there was presentation
where we see how async pitched this
thing as the solution to an increasingly
overpopulated world but how they
ultimately lost their government
contracts when a researcher accidentally
causes a lockdown of the facility all
three of these new videos are full of
lore details but to me the biggest
revelation to come out of these uploads
is that the back rooms aren't just
responsible for warping physical reality
they're also warping time itself
attention all you partygoers i think
i've cracked exactly how and why people
are no clipping into this place but
enough talking friends it's time to go
get lost in these endless hallways of
lore
now despite the video game concept of
noclipping being a key part of the
original creepypasta that the series is
based on kane has yet to explicitly
reference any video game terminology
however after watching this new slate of
videos i'm more convinced than ever that
we're still on the right track for
example
let's take a closer look at pitfalls in
it we follow researcher marvin lee as he
falls to a deeper level of the facility
only to discover a full neighborhood
underground and i do mean full street
lights houses trees all of it well all
of it except for people there are no
signs of life here so either an entire
empty town fell into the back rooms or
this is yet another example of an unused
or incomplete level and when we do get
to enter one of the houses things are
just slightly off inside there are six
inverted street signs just hanging out
in the middle of an empty room almost
like a level designer intended to put
him out on the street but instead just
moved him out of sight into the house
making things even stranger though the
house has a single hallway leading
straight back it's like the uncanny
valley of architecture it's clearly
meant to be a house but it just doesn't
nail it almost like it'd been designed
not by a human but rather by an ai
something that's trying to mimic a human
home but without fully understanding the
flow and function of the various rooms
and hallways but of course it doesn't
end there if you've followed the back
rooms at all you know that kane likes to
hide a bunch of secrets in the
descriptions of his videos and two of
the new uploads report and presentation
link to secret unlisted uploads the
first of these is titled this um i'm
just going to call it numbers because
saying a long string of random digits
every time is going to be a pain this
numbers video seems to be footage from a
traffic camera on a highway nothing too
out of the ordinary right but then about
22 seconds in we see a car no clip
through the ground not only does this
tell us that literally anything can wind
up in the back rooms including large
vehicles like cars but i think we might
be able to figure out who was actually
in that car back in the upload missing
persons we see posters for multiple
people who have disappeared since the
opening of the back rooms one such
poster is for margaret watson the only
poster of the bunch that describes not
only her physical appearance but also
her car her car is a 1987 ford escort
and once you know it but when you
compare the footage from numbers to an
87 ford escort they have the same boxy
appearance so i wouldn't be surprised if
this is meant to be footage of margaret
watson no clipping into the back rooms
on december 2nd 1989 along with her car
but that's not all that we can get out
of the secret upload the digits in the
title of numbers obviously aren't meant
to be random here but what are they all
our usual suspects are out ciphers don't
seem to work it's not a phone number and
it doesn't seem to be long enough for
hex code either no kane decided to get
even more creative with this one that
series of 13 numbers is actually an
international standard book number an
isbn these are unique numeric codes used
to identify books kind of like a
fingerprint for a book and 9780415263573
is linked to a book written by charlotte
perkins gilman the literary classic the
yellow wallpaper yellow wallpaper you
say
if you've never had to read this for
school or even if you did have to read
it for school and you didn't this was a
landmark piece of feminist literature
about a woman slowly going insane after
being forced to stay in a room with ugly
yellow wallpaper she begins to see
moving shapes and people within the
wallpaper and she believes that the ugly
yellow color stains everything that it
touches by the end the woman has peeled
all the wallpaper off the walls trying
to help the person that's trapped inside
only for the woman to then believe that
she's become that person now there's
little direct correlation between the
short story and the backrooms videos but
a lot of its ideas are clearly present
here for example as we see in pitfalls
the bacteria monsters can mimic the
voices of their victims
can you hear me
the monster can also infect the corpses
after killing them like we see with a
victim named nicholas bolton in the
video autopsy report in a way they're
almost replacing their victims the
monsters are trapped in the back rooms
like the people in the wallpaper from
our short story their next step then
should be trying to get out of the
wallpaper out of the back rooms and out
into the real world where they can
infect more framing this in our
simulation theory it's almost like this
is a computer virus infecting reality
corrupting it just like the ugly yellow
color of the wallpaper staining
everything that it touches in the short
story now while all of that's certainly
interesting and i always love a good
excuse to work in a literary reference
it's the second secret video that really
starts to break this thing wide open and
it all boils down to the simpsons this
one is simply called the simpsons and it
fittingly enough features a clip from
the simpsons specifically the episode
bart gets hit by a car i'd like to talk
to you about bringing legal action
against the fiend who did this to your
boy feels super random right i'm just
sitting here watching a simpsons episode
now however the clip glitches out about
35 seconds in and suddenly we're sitting
here watching a spanish commercial for a
cough medication named dymacol and while
i could certainly stand here and draw
parallels between a medicine for cough
syrup and a mutated bacteria monster
running around i don't think it's the
content of these clips that's important
here instead i suspect it's the timeline
of their release you see bart gets hit
by a car premiered in 1991. this timing
makes a lot of sense up to this point
practically all the videos of kane's
backroom series have been dated from the
late 80s or early 90s but the dimecall
commercial really stands out in this
context according to its archive on
youtube this thing didn't hit airwaves
until about 2000. what i suspect is that
async opening portals to the back rooms
temporarily messes with the flow of time
here that simpsons clip from the early
90s is interrupted by a commercial from
the future only for things to return to
normal after async experiment is done
does it sound crazy yeah yeah it does
but it shouldn't time clearly works
differently in the back rooms and this
isn't the only example we have here in
the pitfalls video as marvin moves
further into the hallway in the back of
that weird house the camera glitches
just a bit and if you listen closely you
can hear something playing in the
background
did you hear it it's really hard to make
out but if you listen carefully it's
actually a news broadcast from when cuba
and the united states reopened
diplomatic relations let's compare we'll
make the trip to the us do you think
that your current president president
castro will come visit the united states
[Music]
that specific broadcast it didn't happen
until july of 2015. the date of pitfalls
meanwhile is 1990. in this short scene
we're actually hearing news from 25
years in the future but it doesn't just
stop at news broadcasts or commercials
airing decades out of their own time we
see the physical interference of time as
well as i mentioned earlier the video
presentation shows us async losing their
government contract with the department
of energy because of an emergency
lockdown the thing that causes the
lockdown an async researcher
accidentally enters the control center
for the back rooms not all that big of a
deal right wrong you see it's the same
researcher that saw his team glitch out
and disappear all the way back in
informational video at the end of that
upload we see him open the async control
room and set off the red alert but
here's the thing this guy disappeared on
february 29th 1990. his reappearance in
presentation is on may 8th 1990 over two
months later but clearly he hasn't been
wandering around for that long he's
somehow been transported into the future
this can even go so far as to explain a
discrepancy that i've called out in past
videos in the very first upload of the
series we see a clapper board that
clearly marks the date as july 1990
something but the date in the
description of found footage reads as
september 23rd 1996 a date that's just
completely different from what we saw
written on that clapper board when we
first covered the back rooms i figured
this was just an innocent mistake you
know small error in dates during a point
in the series when dates didn't matter
all that much but now it is clearly
setting up the idea that time works
differently within the back rooms but
that then begs the question how why is
time acting crazy and more importantly
why now well we might actually have an
answer for that you see one of the
secret uploads for the series is an
archive file from march 11 1990. in it
we see the rooms being flooded which
would obviously explain the soggy floors
but more importantly this is where we
first learn about the concept of null
zones now if you don't know what these
are yeah you probably shouldn't they
haven't been explained at all and
they've only been referenced once in the
main series as a passing comment in
pitfalls but what if miller's right
about the null zone in the original
creepypastas lore there were things
called null rooms but kane's
interpretation of the entire back room's
idea has taken a lot of liberties and
his null zones don't seem to relate all
that much to null rooms in any way
outside of just sharing the word null
instead basically all we have to go off
of is this one image it's a bit
difficult to make out dude the quality
of the video but i think it reads due to
the elevation discrepancy between panel
225 and 224 a null kx field is created
it's not much to go off of but at least
it's something and looking back at
pitfalls things start to make a bit more
sense marvin asks about the null zones
after entering an area that's at a
slightly offset elevation look at the
difference in heights between the
hallway and the neighborhood and that
news broadcast from the future the
camera picks it up only as marvin
crosses the threshold of a single stare
in the hallway each time we see an
elevation discrepancy he is crossing a
null zone see the phrase null kx field
caught my eye for a lot of reasons
seemed like a jumping off point that
kane put in so theorists like us could
discover something about the world that
he's building so let's break down what
the phrase could actually mean bit by
bit starting with null in physics a null
is a point where two opposing quantities
cancel each other out basically when two
equal waves meet there's gonna be a
point where they perfectly reflect each
other thereby canceling each other out
the channel electroboom here on youtube
demonstrates this really well using
sound waves right now only the first
speaker is on and i'm gonna stay out of
its way and turn the second speaker on
now i turn the speaker off again
on
off
on
so whatever a null kx field is it's
cancelling something out some sort of a
wave and i have a strong suspicion as to
what those waves might be
electromagnetic waves we see what appear
to be electromagnetic tubes making a
ball disappear in the video prototype
and we hear talk about magnetic field
distortions and other uploads like third
test so it seems like a solid hypothesis
moving on to the kx here we can assume
that the x is a reference to the x-axis
you know x y and z-axes on a
three-dimensional graph that explains
our x which leaves us with k as some
sort of a constant i dug around for
formulas that use the specific kx
nomenclature and while hook's law for
the potential energy of a spring was
certainly a possibility felt like an odd
fit considering the material we're
working with here it seemed far more
likely that the kx here was a reference
to the numerous formulas for
electromagnetic field equations that use
kx as a dimensional point and here's the
thing a lot of our everyday life can be
traced back to electromagnetic waves
light heat electricity radio x-rays
microwaves all of them have a place on
the electromagnetic spectrum and objects
that use or give off those things also
tend to create their own em waves your
phone generates em waves your car em
thanks to its alternator what's more
every person that we've seen no clip
into or experienced strangeness in the
back rooms has been using technology
that uses em waves kane marvin and the
researcher from informational video were
all using electronic cameras to write
information onto magnetic tapes and
margaret wilson she was driving her car
when she no clipped through what if
people are no clipping into the back
rooms because they're unlucky enough to
be in a spot where the electromagnetic
wave from the real world happens to meet
one from the back rooms thereby creating
a null zone cancelling each other out
and letting the person slip through
electromagnetism is also one of the four
fundamental forces of nature that make
up our world if you think of it back in
the terms of a simulated reality of a
video game it's almost like an integral
part of the game engine code that runs
our universe and i think that's
literally the case here within the
universe of the back rooms through their
experiments with electromagnetism async
has glitched their own reality like a
speedrunner that intentionally
manipulates the ram of an old game to
tweak the code and teleport to where
they shouldn't be but this has broken
the rest of the game the rest of reality
and now that part of the game engine is
glitched players are randomly no
clipping into places they shouldn't be
or hearing audio from far away futures
as they wander into these null zones
more and more the world of the back
rooms is starting to sound like the
world's jankiest mmorpg and just like
with a video game exploiting a few
glitches here and there can really cause
the game's stability to collapse which
means it's likely that this is just the
beginning the physical world and time
itself will become more and more
unstable as new rooms are open and as
more people clip in what started as a
high-tech way to expand your garage
storage or squeeze in a few extra
cubicles will suddenly put the entire
world at risk the lines between the real
and the simulated will start to blur to
the point that just like with the woman
in the yellow wallpaper were all
infected we're all going a little mad
we're all the ones trapped inside of the
walls but hey if you've ever felt like
you were glitching out or that you
couldn't trust the reality of your
computer screen it might have just been
used in an unencrypted internet
connection those things are dangerous
friends every time you connect to public
wi-fi at an airport a hotel or a coffee
shop you are at risk of anyone connected
to the same network stealing your
personal information that includes
passwords emails financial details it's
not even that hard i mean i'm not going
to tell you how but i could do it if i
wanted that said with today's sponsor
expressvpn you can protect yourself with
just one easy click expressvpn encrypts
your network data with its best-in-class
encryption and that's not just
protection from hackers you live with
the roommate significant other your
parents well if any of them have admin
access to the network they can see what
you've been doing online and that
definitely includes all the weird pages
you're visiting about electromagnetism
when you're researching back rooms lore
or you know other weird sites that you
might be visiting but if you don't feel
like explaining why you're looking up
time travel conspiracy theories
expressvpn reroutes 100 of your network
traffic so that no one can see what
you're doing but if security is not your
thing what about movies did you know
that streaming services offer different
libraries of content in other countries
cause they do and what's available
outside of the us is way better than
anything you get here with expressvpn
you can change your online location to
one of 94 countries allowing you to
access the best streaming libraries from
anywhere in the world for example if i
hop on over to canada and check out
disney plus they have all the sam raimi
spider-man movies plus films like
deadpool and alien now i don't have to
book a flight to toronto every time i
want to see toby mcguire fight doc ock
so do yourself a favor and get
expressvpn you can get three extra
months for free using our link
expressvpn.com
film theory once again that is three
extra months for free with our link
expressvpn.com
you just click the link down in the
description below because you know no
one wants to type in an actual url and
as always friends i'll see you next week